the Joe Rogan experience you had an
amazing career but one of the things
that I think maybe people aren't as
aware of is what makes your career even
more incredible so you fought for a long
time with a bad shoulder like if you go
back and watch the Carl Froch fight I
watched that getting ready for this I
watch it again
you box the [ __ ] out of him with mostly
your left hand yeah it was crazy
yeah twelve years old
tore my subscapularis which is 50 is
responsible for 50% of the strength in a
rotator didn't really know it at the
time we were told hazed too young you
know he shouldn't have surgery just
rehabbing wrong advice found that out
you know ten years later but we just
rehabbed it with you know bands and
strengthening exercises but we never had
surgery so that was always kind of my
Achilles heel man like I just been
plenty of fights where I just fought
one-handed because it didn't feel strong
it didn't feel like safe I felt like
anytime I would throw it it could pop
out of the socket like that's how it
felt
so it had popped out before it had not
felt like hood got it fixed right around
2013 and it wasn't a hundred but it was
better and I was able to finish out the
rest of my career so I got it still not
100 now it's not a hundred but I'll take
it
yeah I'll take it bro like I probably
gained about 30 40 percent with that
surgery like they grabbed it because the
subscapularis was loose it wasn't
attached but it was an atrophied or
still like a fat thriving muscle just
wasn't attached my doctor was like whoa
like this ever popped out of the socket
dr. Michael Dillingham and in San
Francisco I was like nah he was like how
like your shoulder capsule was like shot
the subscapular thriving muscle let's
get it attached boom he attached it like
a four-hour surgery something like that
one of those surgeries that you're not
guaranteed to come out of the same and
you had to wait for a month or so to see
if the surgery took like if everything
with mend and kind of get you know kind
of get stronger
it took men and like I said I finished
out the rest of my career strong wow so
how long was the rehab high by eight
months so you went from it was about
2012 to 2015 where you didn't fight very
often as it was that very frequently
yeah
because of the show combination of a
lawsuit and the injury mm yeah it's kind
of like back-to-back blows so for eight
months you're rehabbing it and just
still like when did you know that for
sure you're gonna be able to come back
you kind of turn the corner in rehab you
know three three month mark you know
four-month mark you kind of realized to
do like I'm good like I'm not where I
need to be but like I'm headed there so
about that time about halfway through
you realize that you're gonna be okay it
just gonna take some time to fully get
the strength back but even my next fight
against Edwin Rodriguez like I still
didn't throw it and I didn't realize I
didn't throw it until i watch the tape i
watch the table thing Hey it was like a
one-handed affair and then after that
think about injuries is weird like that
12-month period for me has always been
like just like that sweet spot so I got
to that 12-month period with the
shoulder you know I've said my overhand
right came back hadn't thrown over here
right in ten years you know my the power
and my right uppercut came back on I
know this is getting better so after
that then you started to see that thing
flying and started whistling and and
ironically enough my last fight that was
the punch that started all the trouble
for Sergey Kovalev
well it's interesting because you were
so successful with one hand you know it
makes you wonder like what how goddamn
good would you have been if you had two
hands or was it your left hand was so
educated that'd be it had to be but one
of the things you were so good at man
was I have to tell you you know this was
using your jab to shut down southpaw
fighters shut down their jab and counter
you know and you just had that you had
like extra juice with your left hand
because you used it so I had to like
when you have one hand or one arm that
that functions really well like you
learn to make that thing great like you
know you overcompensate and that's what
that left hand was overcompensation
because I didn't have the right hand to
fall back on you know but the whole
southpaw thing
shoutout to my boy [ __ ] and ideas like
in all the work we've done and can't
like those guys got me ready for a lot
of myself part opponents like you know
midway through and toward the end of my
career so a lot of work with those guys
and specifically Nate at a certain point
I stopped working with Nick because he
was doing other things but Nate men and
the volume and having to like deal with
the awkwardness and heighten the reach
and like that got me ready for Chad
Dawson
[Applause]